i want to show you a better way to do
this and it's going to be built off of
the way lucia did it okay so
um
i want us to do this okay
um and you're gonna need to do some
drawing with me okay so if you haven't
written down k plus three equals five
already okay i want you to write it out
now i want you to imagine that this this
guy here
uh all of these guys actually i want you
to imagine that they're
three oh sorry not three k that's k
alright so i'm going to stick him on the
board
there's k
all right so why don't you draw like a
little up sorry a bigger bigger square
there
and these individuals here are can never
get these apart okay
these guys here each one of these is
just worth one is that okay
here's one so
here's well i want an individual
here's two you get the idea okay so over
here
i've got k
plus i need three of these right and you
need to draw three as well so i'm going
to put these up okay
here we go
yes
absolutely you do
and thank you and sonia for putting
these together for me
all right
there you go
there's my k plus three is that okay so
far so good
what am i gonna have the right set i
need five of these
let's see okay hold on hold on
okay
there you go
right
now
i'm gonna go after what um lucia said is
her method for doing this okay
she said
i took
three away from five now can you see why
that works let's think about it okay
why would you take three away from five
well we want to know what k is right we
want to find out we want to solve we
want to get the solution okay so if i
take three over here
right i take three away from this
then i should take three away
from here as well
right
yes
because if i take three from one side i
should take it from the other now
you're like okay that's still a bit
magical to me i i don't buy it okay
sure it ends up on the right solution
but why is that okay well let me try and
sell this to you a little more
this is an equation right
something is the same as something else
okay
so another way of thinking about it
is like
two things that are equal to each other
now let me see
how does a set of scales work
okay well very simply
if you put something on one side
okay he goes down because that's heavier
can you see it you can
this side is lower because it's heavier
right but if i put the same thing on the
other side
cool he starts to go back to normal okay
eventually after you'll stop moving let
me see if i can do it
if you look really really closely right
on the front here you can actually see a
pair of triangles and they should be
pointing right to each other
unfortunately it scales a bit old so
it's not the best but you get the idea
okay
now it balances okay what would this be
um what would this mean what would this
mean
as an equation how would you write that
well i've got i've got one of these on
both sides
right
so this is saying something not very
dramatic
it's saying k equals k
well i hope so right
now here's what's interesting okay
i'm gonna um i'm gonna go after this
okay let's actually change this equation
a bit
and get some different numbers on here
okay
we're going to form an equation
off of this let's see
um give me a number give me a number how
many how many of these should i put on
this side
not too big four four
four i'll do
i can do six later
okay
so as you expected
um it hits the ground of course it's the
ground right it's heavier because you've
got 4k here you just got 1k there of
course all right
so what i'm going to do is i'm going to
start putting these little guys over on
this side okay now you guys can't see
all four of them so i'll put them on do
you see that
there you go okay good
so the question is well how many of
these am i going to put over here right
let's see well i actually know how many
i need to cook
oh
oh
i'll put them in so you can count
how's your counting 14.
all right
now i'll admit it's not perfect
but it's
close i i think we're going to call it
close enough for today okay because we
can play this forever and the scales are
going to keep on you know wobbling
around
what have i got well i count 4k on one
side
4k
on the other side my count here is one
two three four five six seven eight nine
10 11 12 13 14 15
16.
on the other
okay now
let's just see what happens
for instance i mean obvious stuff right
obvious obvious stuff
if i took
one each of these wrong color sorry
one each of these
because i have a set of scales right i
should be able to add this onto both
sides and it should stay balanced right
set of scales yeah if i do something to
one side
well down it goes
and it works right it's still balanced
what equation would correspond to you
can't see it really can you
what equation would correspond to this
yeah
hold on what equation corresponds to
this what did i do to both sides
i added
one of these guys
right the same as both sides so it looks
to me like
i added one to this side
so i added one to this side what's 16
plus one
okay now
these equations
they're equivalent to each other right
they represent the same set of numbers
the important thing i want to get across
to you is
when you do something to one side you do
it to the other is that okay
all right let me take off that extra one
again
what else could i do
okay
yeah
yeah i could i totally could i could add
a k over here
and a k over here what equation would
that be
how many of how many k's have i got over
there
i've got five of them right
5k what have i got on the other side
i've got 16 little guys
plus a k right
all of these are equivalent you do
something to one side
you do it to the other okay now
we wanted to find a solution didn't we
okay
now just so happens right that this this
is a new set of equations to this one so
in fact just so you're not confused i'm
gonna pop this guy off
i wanna know
uh what's 1k
what's 1k now i'll get rid of this extra
one over here
so have a look
remember we've been saying if you do
something to one side you've got to do
it to the other right
so
4k that's actually an abbreviation right
what's an abbreviation for
it's four times k
or k
times four because multiplication is
commutative right
so if i want to
get rid of the four over here and just
get k on his own
i should do the opposite of multiplying
by four right what's the opposite of
multiplying by four
dividing by four
is that okay yeah
if i divide this side by four
i should divide the other side by four
as well
okay so watch what happens
i'm going to divide this up look here go
there's my um there's one quarter of
that side and there's the other three
quarters is that okay
and here is one quarter this side and
three quarters of the other there you go
i've separated them out
so now i can actually do the division
there's a quarter left on that side
and
there's a quarter left
on that side and if i still a little bit
it balances so what equation is this
k on one side and of course on the other
side
four
does that make sense
so
4 or k equals 4 is the value that makes
this equation work k equals 4 is what do
we call that
the
solution so we've solved the equation
in summary
whenever you have an equation like this
okay
i want you to picture this guy i want
you to picture a set of scales okay
something
equals something else okay
so if we want to get a solution if we
want to solve it it's like well with our
previous example you can guess like you
i asked you to guess before how many do
you think it would take to balance it
out right that's a very slow method
a quicker way is to think okay what can
i do to both sides that'll keep it even
okay
you know what we had before was k plus 3
right
there's k plus three there
so i would have seven on this side
wouldn't i
and it would balance
sorry i moved it
there you go that easy to see
k plus three here
seven here right so of course
to undo adding three right i would
subtract three right like so three from
here
and three
from here you've always got to make sure
it
balances does that make sense
yep
excellent okay